a packed agenda for justin trudeau as he
visits four european countries between
now and friday meeting with a number of
world leaders who share canada's
position in support of ukraine figuring
out the next best steps to push back on
russia discussing
how to continue to support ukraine
how to strengthen democratic values
around the world and how to stand up
even more for democracy to stand against
russia aggression
and to work very hard on combating the
kind of disinformation and
misinformation that we know is
a facet of
day-to-day life these days but a
particularly strong facet of uh this
conflict this war in ukraine
trudeau's first stop is london where he
will sit down with british prime
minister boris johnson as well as dutch
prime minister mark ruta trudeau's
office says they will discuss building
on their coordinated response to
russia's unjustifiable military
aggression but government officials
won't share exactly what kinds of
proposals may be on the table in terms
of pushing back just that they're aiming
for maximum impact last week canada
announced a variety of different
sanctions nearly daily as well as aid
for ukraine in london trudeau will also
have an audience with the queen
during the latvian portion of trudeau's
trip in addition to meeting with baltic
leaders and nato secretary general you
will also meet with canadian troops
stationed there leading a nato battle
group there are currently 540 canadian
troops with more on the way
another focus of the trip the
humanitarian crisis unfolding as more
than a million ukrainians flee that
country that will be top of mind as
trudeau visits poland which has seen
hundreds of thousands of ukrainians
across the border there abigail beeman
global news ottawa